[Music]
Well, hello dear friends. Welcome to our
question and answer program. I'd like to
know. This is a program where you send
us your questions, then we do the
research, and then we answer the
questions according to the research that
we've done. Uh we don't do this program
live. because uh when the question is
asked live uh there's a tendency just to
give an answer to the question a quick
answer to the question but we want to be
thorough in our answering of the
questions and that's why we don't do it
live but we do the research and then we
answer the questions online uh we want
to give you the email address if you
want to send us your questions uh you
can do so at the following address
you'll see it on the screen tvsumtv.org
org. Once again, tvsumtv.org.
We'd be delighted to get your questions.
We learn a lot on this program because
you force us to go and do research into
questions that perhaps we haven't even
thought about. And so we we long for
your questions and we put them in order
of course which means that we might not
answer them in the next program but we
will answer them in the order in which
we receive them.
>> I have with me Pastor David Salasar.
He's the CEO of uh STV Latino. Uh he's
in charge of our Spanish speaking work
which we have a very very strong Spanish
department here. and uh he and pastor
Mandria do a fabulous job and it's
really good to work with you.
>> Thank you pastor Boris. It's always an
honor to be with you to receive your
guidance, your mentoring and it's a
blessing to again participate of this
program that helps us to study a lot.
>> Praise the Lord. Well, we never want to
begin a program without prayer.
>> We need God's wisdom to answer every
question.
>> Absolutely.
>> And so I would like to ask Pastor
Salasad if you would please have prayer
for us. Absolutely. Let us pray. Our
gracious heavenly father, we come before
you to the throne of grace to uh first
of all thank you for the gift of your
son to die for us in the cross and for
allowing us to also receive the gift of
the Holy Spirit that we may understand,
may be guided to all truth, may be
taught by you through your word to
understand truly what you have explained
or have shared with us. And we ask Lord
that you will give us the wisdom that
comes from you so that we may receive it
and share and impart rightful knowledge,
rightful answers that may be according
to the scriptures and according to your
will. We thank you of your for for being
with us. We pray this in Jesus name.
Amen.
>> Amen.
Well, we're going to begin with a
question that I don't remember ever
getting before here on our program. It's
a very good question.
>> Yeah. Um, it comes from Anan.
We're not told exactly where uh he comes
from, but I think that's a pseudonym.
But anyway, um I want to read the
question and I know that you've done a
lot of research into this. So, um I'm
going to throw it to you and I'm sure
you'll give a good answer.
>> Uh here's the question. Do you agree
with the effective deconstruction of
Ellen White's direct revelation
statement about SDAs and life insurance?
And of course, the source he's
mentioning is uh volume one of the
testimonies 549 to 551.
So once again, he says uh by Ellen G.
White's estate document. In other words,
the the white estate wrote a document
because people asked the question about
life insurance. Uh the question
continues, does Leng Whites providing
for the future in quotation marks
council actually mean living within
one's means and so also quotation marks
again making personal savings from
actual income for future obligations or
just relying on the postdeath payout of
a life insurance policy.
The brother keep brother's keeper
principles in Ellen White's revelational
council in one testimonies 113 to 115
seems to explain or define more what
insurance provisions should be amongst
SDAs including in regards to health
insurance given the abundant resources
SDAs have in that field 7th day avenous
and life insurance LG write white
writings and then he gives a source
for this.
>> So what can we say about uh procuring
life insurance? Is it the same today as
it was back in the times of Ellen White?
What we what can we say about this?
>> Well, pastor, I know that the question
that this uh friend is sending. It's a
good question. It really seems that he
or she is wondering uh is it wrong to
have life insurance? uh a spirit
prophecy as it's we can quote there in
testimonies to the church volume 1 page
549 551 it's very direct and when we
read that and I I I have the whole um
text here but it would probably be uh
quite a reading but I'll just read the a
couple of paragraphs of this
selection of this paragraph so that we
can actually see what she's saying it
says there I was shown that
Sabbathkeeping Adventists should not
engage engage in life insurance. This
isn't this is a commerce with the world
which God does not approve. Those who
engage in this enterprise are uniting
with the world while God calls his
people to come out from among them and
to be separate.
Then she says life insurance is a
worldly policy which leads our brethren
who engage in it to depart from the
simplicity and purity of the gospel.
Every such departure weakens our faith
and lessens our spirituality.
Then she says, "God designs that we
should preserve in simplicity and
holiness or pecularity as a people those
who engage in this worldly policy in
best means which belong to God which he
has entrusted to them to use in his
cause to advance his work. But few will
realize any returns from life insurance.
And without God's blessing even these
will prove an injury instead of a
benefit. So here are some of the you
know segments that I have you can see
that are seems to be very clear that she
says life insurance is not a good
practice. It's separated from the from
God. It's a worldly endeavor. It does
not really pay etc. And they're using
the means that are sent that should be
used for the Lord in such a practice.
Now, this was something that she wrote
uh in the uh 1867.
So, it's important to know that what
she's mentioned here was written in a
time where insurance, specifically life
insurance, was not regularized. It was
somewhat uh very fraudulent. the the
ways that they would do it. It was more
like a gambling system where you would
sort of, you know, make efforts to
receive a large sum of money expecting
in a way that somebody or you will die
or or somebody that you put the life
insurance will will die and you can
benefit from. So it was really uh a way
to get a get rich quickly. But that is
not necessarily what is today. Now
having said that I want to share some
Bible verses that I think are important
to understand how really uh the we as a
Christians need to understand and then
to be able to understand what she was
trying to say through this. I will go
through the verse. First verse is in 1
Timothy chapter 5:8. Actually, pastor
Well, you probably can read that for us.
1 Timothy 5:8
and um that's a verse that the apostle
Paul speaks to us uh that we need to
think about. Uh 1 Timothy 5:8 says, "But
if anyone does not provide for his own
and especially for those of his
household, he has denied the faith and
is worked worse than an unbeliever."
That's a strong statement.
>> That's very strong statement. So here we
have a a a very clear definition of God
saying if you are a you know if you are
a man and you have a household you have
to be responsible to provide for them
and do everything you can to provide for
their needs. It doesn't mean to provide
them for riches or to you know to have
an idleness of life. No, but it means to
provide for them. Now, in uh Proverbs
13:22
and uh also Proverbs 27:20, maybe you
can go pro to Proverbs 27:20 while I
read Proverbs 13:22.
>> It says there, "A good man leaves an
inheritance to his children's children,
but the wealth of the sinner is stored
up for the righteous." Here, here we
have a verse that's very clear in
regards to we need to provide for our
posterity. It's important that we plan
that we don't make um we don't squander
off what the Lord has given us and that
we actually can provide for our children
and for those who are after us even you
know if we're not there that they can
prov have something to to live off. So
now let's read Proverbs 27:12.
>> A prudent man foresees evil and hides
himself.
the simple pass on and are punished. So
we see here in this verse that the Lord
advises and the wise individual is
preventing something some calamity you
know he plans for a rainy day if you
will if if something happens there is a
plan before it is not you know we're uh
sort of providing ahead of the situation
that may arise now I say all this
because uh this the there was actually a
committee of study committee that uh
back in the 1950s that looked upon these
particular quotes from Liz White to see
if these quotes were actually in a sense
uh going against the actual and the
current time experience or or or or way
that life insurance works. And for that
matter, not just life insurance, health
insurance, uh home insurance, car
insurance, any type of insurance.
Because again, we have to understand
that these things that today many of us
have to have uh if we were to just go by
the first verses, we may find ourselves
that may are we, you know, breaking the
the council, are we taking into
something that we should not have?
Should we not have health insurance,
life insurance, car insurance, house
insurance since these practices
according to prophecy seem to be evil or
seem to be worldly? But again, I think
that's important to when we understand
the reason why she said that and compare
it to how it is today and especially in
where we live in this country. Uh in
some other countries like in Europe, you
don't really need to worry about
necessarily health insurance because
it's a system insurance, you know, for
your example. So the, you know, the
system provides for you. But here in
this country, if you don't have health
insurance, uh, you're going to be in a
really big problem. If, you know, unless
you're really poor and then you have a
federal life, you know, Medicaid or
something like that. Uh, but if you have
a job, you have wages, and you don't
have health insurance, you're going to
be out of a lot of money in a very small
manner. you know whether you are sick
you just go to the hospital and you have
to have a like I had a kidney stone for
example one time one two nights in the
hospital the bill was $50 some thousand
dollars and you're like I mean how can I
afford that had I not had health
insurance guess what I would have been
out a lot of money so the reason why I
say that is because the spirit of
prophecy or the the any white state made
this document and this is where I know
that our friend has looked into this
document and he or she says that they
have deconstructed but I don't think
it's a dis deconstruction when you
actually are supporting what she says
and just making it presented in the way
that needs to apply to our time under
the current regulations of insurance. Uh
let me just briefly share the uh this
well there's actually 19 points that
they make in regard to this. So I'm
going to try to go uh you know slowly
about this but it's important to
understand how they came with this
report. Again this was done in 1957. Uh
it was a 50-page report but it's
summarized in these 19 uh particular
points and I'm going to read them and
and you can comment pastor as well. says
that the spirit of prophecy uh the first
one is that the spirit of prophecy
counelss unhesitantly and definitely
teach that the Christians should make
provision for a rainy day. We should
recognize that a time will come when
there will be reduced or terminated
income and looking ahead we should if
possible have a reasonable amount of
property or money in reserve to meet
such needs that the charities of others
needs not to be dependent upon. So
that's the first point that they uh
emphasize based on the spirit of
prophecy council. Second one that it is
proper to have the security of a modest
home of our own and conservative
financial investments money in the bank
investment the lord's work or another
sound investment. Number three that is
proper to avail ourselves of the
protection offered by fire insurance and
insurance of the automobile.
This is uh third point, fourth point
that in whatever provision is made for
future needs, the Christian is ever
mindful of the special and tender watch
care of God over his children and he is
not forgetful of the needs of the cause
of God. Number five, that the family in
the church have responsibility to its
members in time of need or beravement.
The Christian sharing his brother's
burden so that none will suffer. Number
six, that just what provision be made
for the day of need and how it shall be
arranged must be left with the
individual to settle carefully and
prayerfully with heart fully surrendered
to God and with the determination in the
heart that is fulfilling these
responsibilities. Every money I mean
every move rather may be moved in a
harmony with God's will. Number seven,
that the spirit of prophecy council of
life insurance made in 1960s were given
at a time when life insurance was
uncontrolled and often handled by fly by
night concerns more or less as a
gambling position in a get-richquick
scheme. Number eight, the spirit of
prophecy councils in the years between
1867 and 1809 were consistent in
discouraging life insurance. But in the
United States, such insurance did not
come under the control of the state
banking laws until 1906 and onward. And
as late as 1910, some companies were
involved in questionable and often
dishonest practices. There were no
statements of life insurance from Alwite
after 1909.
Then number verse nine, the or nine that
various savings and insurance plans
today termed life insurance protected as
they are by carefully enacted state laws
and subject to close inspection of state
authorities are generally considered a
safe and sound investment. sounder than
many other investments. 10. That in most
so-called life insurance as it is today
written, there's actually carried out
the principle of putting something aside
from the day of need and of sharing on
another's burden. The circle reaching
out beyond the family of the church
include a quite a large number of
persons, thus equalizing the burden and
minimizing the expense. 11. The
healthcare insurance is simply another
plan for equalizing what may be an
unusual and heavy expense. a large
number of persons sharing the burden of
one another. 12. The burial insurance
provides a means whereby the expenses
now connected with the death is provided
for in a certain insured manner through
advanced payments over a period of
years. 13. In the burial societies of
which large numbers of persons
participate either by specified dues or
by assessments at the time of the death
of a member are a means of
systematically spreading the expense in
such a way that we bear one another's
burden and through a wellorganized plan
make proper provision for expenses which
must be made. And uh verse uh point 14,
the social security is recognized by the
church as a plan whereby employer and
wager and wage earner unite in
systematically placing in reserve that
which will be available in time of need
either a retirement or a death. 15. that
these various plans virtually
accomplished for the lay member wage
earner what the dominational retirement
plan called into being through the
spirit of prophecy has for many years
provided for ministers and for other
employees of the domination applying by
which a regular percentage of the
payroll of the various employing
organizations is accumulated in one
central fund to be disbured in monthly
payments to retire or incapacitated
laborers or their widows and in the case
of need in meeting unusual medical and
burial expense. 16 that the 7th
Adventist Church although it does not
encourage or discourage members in the
matter of insurance of different types
has by actions of the general conference
committee in annual council formally
placed its approval on social security
and survivors benefit plans. 17 that the
choice of the method employed in
providing a capital of means to use in
case of emergency. Whatever the method
shall be, care should be taken to seek
and follow the council of those
experienced who can be dependent upon
the give and to give safe guidance. 18
and almost done here. That whatever
provision the wage earner makes in
provision for the day of financial
adversity or lessen income, he must
guard carefully against a course of
action which will lead to a love of to a
love of money or to a creation of his
own hands of something in which he
places his trust as to impair that close
connection to his creator and redeemer.
And the 19th and the last point of this
uh uh committee was that the lord
through the spirit of prophets councils
has given us abundant of instructions
and guidance relating to our
responsibility for financial stewardship
making clear our obligations to God our
family our fellow church members and
those about us and these councils should
be carefully studied restudied and
adhered to that we may lay up treasures
in heaven lest Satan lure us into soul
destroying entanglements so these are 19
points and you can actually see this uh
there's in the spirit prophecy website
the white website also in the bible
research institute website is the same
article there but it's pretty much given
us the right understanding of how to
explain the quotes of white and how it
does not really apply to the experience
of today how life insurance is not how
it was done in her time and so
furthermore more again if we are to
understand that God wants us to make
provision. It's not about making
ourselves rich. It's not about uh like
in the other part she that this
individual mentions uh which I also
studied the brother keeper where she's
actually making a call for people to not
add money or properties to themselves
not to burden themselves with a lot of
debt and to get life insurance for
example for paying debts. See that's not
the plan. That's not the purpose of of
what the Lord was trying to say is not
to get ourselves a lot of things and
get, you know, riches and properties and
buy houses and homes and land. Uh that's
not the point. It's about being smart
and making provision for when you are
not available or when you have uh a
need. Let's say a fire destroys your
home. You have insurance for that. Let's
say that uh you know you are the bread
winner of your home and something
happens to you. You're not leaving your
children and your wife or your widow
without any provision. These are
different than what she was
establishing. So I think that I I I will
ask this individual to uh re-evaluate
and again maybe the comparison might be
a little different but I believe that
the there's enough for us to understand
that this council and what the white
state came up with it's a it's a sound
council is a sound response and it gives
us a good balance uh view of this of
this particular point.
>> See this is the reason folks that we
don't answer questions live. Yeah,
>> because because there's a lot of
research that needs to go into this and
you've done a really fantastic job
answering this question. I just want to
add a couple of things.
>> Number one, I think that when those
regulations were adopted, those councils
were adopted. Yeah.
>> The head of the white estate was Ellen
White's grandson, Arthur White.
>> Uh so you and he never objected uh to to
those councils that are there. Secondly,
you know, some people say, "Well, I'm
not going to make provision uh for uh
health insurance. You know, the Lord is
going to heal me." Or they'll say, "Uh,
you know, uh, I'm not going to make
provision for my family when I die
because God's going to take care of
them." The line of faith and the line of
predom presumption
go very close together.
>> Yeah.
uh you know it's presumptuous to say the
Lord will take care of it when there are
ways in which the Lord can use through
us to make provision for our relatives
when we die. I've always said that it
should be called death insurance not
life insurance because the person who
dies has no benefit.
>> Absolutely.
>> The benefit is for benefit is for his
family. And you pastor you you were you
know mentioning to me the main thing
about life insurance or any type of
insurance is what is your motivation
really right you know if if you are
trying to uh put insurance on your
spouse you know life insurance hoping
that that person dies and make yourself
rich that's you know that's an evil
practice and God will see your heart and
will judge accordingly you know but if
you get
>> on your own on on you on yourself life
insurance
>> just in Hey, something happens to you
and it's not taking away from your
responsibility with God, with your
family, you know, uh I mean it's
something that you can put aside as a
means to provide in case something
happens to you. It's actually fulfilling
the principle that we just read in the
Bible. That's why I went through those
Bible verses first to understand that
God does require us to plan ahead. Now
again within our means within our
possibilities if you are not able to pay
for that well yeah you can't
>> right
>> you know but
>> well our time is just about up uh I want
to encourage all of those who are
watching to uh please continue to pray
for us and also to support us
financially you know it uh costs a
considerable sum for us to produce the
programming that we have here at secrets
unsealed. We appreciate all of those who
support us. May the Lord bless you and
we hope to see you on our next program.
I'd like to know where we will attempt
to answer your questions. God bless.
[Music]